some people in the most prominent jobs
in America don't seem to know
anything about their own jobs
there's only one person who's just
behind that Resolute desk
and the decisions that that person has
to make are the decisions that nobody
else in the country can make and he's an
extraordinary leader
right there
so Kamala Harris is obviously describing
the job of the president but what's a
little awkward here is
Stephen Colbert had just asked her what
does the vice president do and so she
gives this answer there's only one
person there Joe Biden he's so great
he's such a wonderful leader he's so
great and so the audience applauds
presumably be as a sign lit up telling
them to applaud but then Stephen Colbert
leans in
[Applause]
[Music]
that's an excellent answer and uh the
question was what is the job of the vice
president
your answer is part of the job I'm
guessing well you know my job is is due
I mean for example I'll tell you I was
recently in Munich at the Munich
security conference and
um and the job there was to stand up and
as you know most of my career I spent as
a prosecutor and I declared that we the
United States of America believe that
Russia has committed crimes against
humanity
so and she goes on and on and on and on
and at no point
by my telling
did she ever answer the question what
does the vice president do this is not a
trick question Kamala this is not a
gotcha you're the vice president of the
United States you ought to be able to
answer what does the vice president do
what does the vice president do well the
vice president uh it casts the
tie-breaking vote in the Senate resides
over the Senate the the vice president
of the United States is One Heartbeat
Away from the president and serves uh in
a supporting role for the president of
the United States the vice president
raises money for the the party of the
president that's an unofficial role but
that's certainly one of the jobs and
what does she say because the vice
president is someone who well uh okay I
went I took a trip to Germany
and my job there was
um to uh you know Putin's bad
um Putin is really bad so yeah
she doesn't know what her job is
Joe Biden I'm not convinced knows what
his job is and the job of the president
is much more clearly defined than the
vice president and Joe Biden's been in
government for well over 50 years now at
the federal level
neither of them know what the job is
because they are convenience politicians
I've long said there are two kinds of
politicians convenience politicians and
conviction politicians
can conviction politicians are the ones
who go out with a vision
this is what I want the country to look
like
convenience politicians are the ones who
go out to just be the position
and to get a post office named after
them and to have people applaud when
they say platitudes
Biden and Harris are both of that sort I
I don't even mean to disparage them in
particular there are plenty of
convenience politicians on the
Republican side too who just want to be
something and go along and get along but
they're not conviction politicians
that's why they have been so successful
within the liberal establishment
Kamala Harris is rather unimpressive we
don't need to get into all of the
reasons that she's had a successful
political career but one of them I think
is that she's basically nothing I think
it's the same thing with Joe Biden
because they wake up in the morning they
lick their little finger they put it up
in the air and they figure out which way
the wind is blowing and that's fine they
go where their handlers tell them to go
they don't even really know what their
job is
that's why the blob the Deep State the
bureaucracy the liberal establishment
whatever you want to call it that's why
it tends to gravitate toward those kinds
of politicians because it's going to
keep rolling along and they're not going
to cause any trouble and they're not
going to be particularly accountable to
the people now someone doesn't know what
the job is and someone wants the job
very very badly apparently and that
would be Governor Ron DeSantis
people are saying you've been telling
people you have to stay in your home and
like in Florida they were killing us
because even in those early days you
know when we were following federal
guidelines Loosely but we were filing
some we were playing golf I mean The
Villages they're setting record for golf
people are boating all this stuff they
were so mad at Florida for doing that
people on the beach all this stuff that
was their position you are killing
people if you leave your house so then
all these people are like thousands of
people are protesting 2 000 of these
epidemiologists write a letter saying we
do not condemn these protests uh because
of covet indeed we think they're vital
for public health right because they're
fighting it's a bigger disease yes and
so that's that's when I knew
is this this public health this public
health uh a clan of people they are sick
I mean they are they are ideologically
captured and these are not people that
should be anywhere near the levers of
power these are sick people I actually
got to ask Governor DeSantis once at a
dinner I said how did you know how would
you willing to take the political bet
to reopen Florida because forget about
the public health threat for a second
politicians govern in their own interest
to so that they don't get thrown out of
office so I said you know if you got
that wrong you would have had your
complete political career destroyed how
were you confident enough to take the
BET and he gave me a very simple answer
he said I looked at the charts I had Top
Doctors giving me the charts I knew how
viruses work they go up they Plateau
they go down it's very simple I I was
confident in that and that's what
happened
and then you hear him explain here to
Glenn back
Governor DeSantis looks at all these
Public Health officials who are making
things up the moment that he saw the
corruption of
stay in your homes don't go to your
grandmother's funeral don't go to
Christmas oh but if you want to go burn
down a courthouse for BLM that's
important because whiteness is the real
disease he just said this is sick this
is obviously
not based on any kind of epidemiological
science
okay we're going to reopen
now all of this matters because there's
been a debate
in the GOP for about six seven years now
and the two sides have been should the
GOP wield government power in a just way
but effectively when we have the
opportunity or should we not wield
government power because that's big
government and big government's bad and
we need a neutral sphere and we
shouldn't push back too hard and the
best government is the smallest
government it should fit in the size of
into our pockets and that's that those
are the two sides of the debate you know
which side I'm on I wrote a whole book
about this and I talk about it every
single day obviously I think the
conservatives need to wield more power
or we're just going to seed the whole
ground to the libs which is why
Republicans win Democrats when the libs
agenda keeps advancing so I said yes we
need to wield government power
most of the GOP previously and much of
if not most of the conservative movement
said the opposite don't wield too much
power light touch let it go let's stay
neutral okay I think it's pretty clear
which side is winning right now I think
in terms of the argument I think our
side has won the debate and so you've
got two candidates in particular
articulating The View that I've been
advocating that would be Trump and
DeSantis
actually others in the GOP field as well
but because they're the two top
candidates
those are the two that that are really
getting these ideas out there right now
they're both on the same side of that
question wield more government power
Trump was the one as as a candidate and
as an elected politician who was really
breaking through here it was really
getting this message across so the
question when you're deciding between
Trump and DeSantis then becomes not so
much what do they believe where are the
shades where do they fall on the issues
they agree on the issues they even agree
on the the medium they even agree on the
tactics of wielding government power the
question it seems then becomes
who can most effectively
wield state power
against our opponents
and in favor of justice and in favor of
the good and in favor of a good normal
country
that's a question who can do it best who
do you trust to do it
the best let's say it's pretty simple
stuff that's like that's democracy 101
and we forget that sometimes when we
become so ideological we have a great
member block coming up
that would be with a man who you may
have seen on social media his name is
Dave Danna
Dave was very very overweight
his weight was somewhere around 420
pounds
420 nice but it wasn't nice and he knew
that it wasn't nice so he said I want to
lose weight
I'm going to say no to body positivity
this body positivity movement that
encourages people to be unhealthy really
body negativity if you ask me and he's
been hitting the gym
and he's been getting a ton of support
from some of the biggest figures in
in
among celebrities among Fitness people
among and he's really taken off the rest
of the show continues now you don't want
to miss it become a member and use code
Knowles Canada wlas at check out for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]